haben sie wahrscheinlich auch verfolgt
unser europaparlament war diese woche
mal echt fleißig freunde ja erst haben
sie die neue urheberrechtsreform fürs
internet durchgewunken und sich so mal
eben mit einer kompletten generation
versaut aber dann ist ihnen tatsächlich
auch noch was relativ kluges eingefallen
für lkw und busse sind sogenannte
abbiege assistenten bald europaweit
pflicht und das ist höchste zeit
regelmäßig sterben radfahrer im toten
winkel von lastern überhaupt ist radl in
deutschland ja oft so eine art nightmare
on elm street wirklich nein wirklich
jetzt ich meine was hat man von
aufgemalten radwegen wenn die entweder
alle paar meter zugeparkt sind oder man
zum überleben lustigen lkw slalom fahren
muss also kurz gesagt in deutschen
städten ist für alles was nicht auto
heißt leider sehr wenig platz und es
gilt das recht des stärkeren
jeder hasst jeden radler ist einfach
uneinsichtig war wieder denken sie haben
immer vorfahrt die von immer neben den
radwegen sind auf einmal da
ja ja das auto bleibt bei uns halt die
krone der schöpfung und als so oft wird
man so zum radeln im stau haufen das ist
so die zahl der getöteten radfahrer ist
bei uns im letzten jahr um 13,6 prozent
gestiegen auf 432 tote in nordrhein
westfalen vor unglück alle 31 minuten
ein wobei muss man dazu sagen die gefahr
natürlich manchmal auch vom radfahrer
ausgehen gerade jetzt wo ist diese
komischen pedelecs gibt elektrofahrräder
auf dem man nicht mehr so viel treten
muss da erleben deutsche städte einen
ganz neuen terror sie verwerten angst
und schrecken auch deutschlands
sternchen rentner auf e bikes medien
tote gebirge liegt nicht mehr aus der
mode gekommen brettern durch die stadt
guiyang gilt auf der flucht vor ihm
vertrauen
gruppenbild nicht denn sie haben ihr
hörgerät schon vor jahren ausgeschaltet
sie halten sich für unverwundbar
weil sie ja auch stalingrad überlebt
haben rentner auf e bikes schlimmer sind
nur rentner auf segways
gefahr
langsam wird es wirklich kritische
kritisch und eng und auf so engem raum
kämpfen autofahrer radfahrer fußgänger
und hunde um jeden zentimeter so und als
wäre das nicht schlimm genug dazu kommt
jetzt noch ein völlig neuer player
wissen sie nie scooter elektro roller
sind der neue heiße scheiß findet
jedenfalls ein gewisser warte mal an die
scheuer
ich bin für alle mobilitätsformen offen
ich bin heute wieder elektro roller
gefahren leider nur in meinem
ministerium was heißt leider gottseidank
fährst du damit nicht draußen
jetzt war ganz ernsthaft sonst kriegt
der mann originalen nichts gebacken
diese woche ist zum beispiel seine
verkehrskommission für den klimaschutz
in einem absoluten fiasko geendet aber
wir brauchen dringend mehr e roller
findet er ist klar ist klar absolut das
ist die lösung für sämtliche probleme
wir fangen jetzt alle nur noch die rolle
so fährt sich das jetzt schon in wien
und in tel aviv und in paris ja echt
schade und claus klebers katze diese
rasenden roller solle noch vor dem
sommer auch auf deutschen straßen
offiziell zugelassen werden was ich
immer sage wenn was wirklich wichtig ist
reagiert unsere politik auch mal schnell
allerdings ist der coole e-roller
manchen immer noch nicht innovativ genug
in ordnung hier vorgelegt worden ist die
umfasst eben nicht das was da kommt in
der zukunft die so eng gefasst dass
beispielsweise kinderwagen es wird das
neueste ding sein weit gar nicht damit
erreicht werden können roth kinderwagen
was ist das denn kinder war
ach so
spieltag
huber ja
beide auch im kinderwagen zur arbeit
warum nicht ansonsten streitet
deutschland wissen sie gerade sehr
hysterisch über diese neue kampagne aus
schatzministerium das ist ein gut
gemeintes plädoyer für fahrradhelme
looks like shit bad selbst mal live
weber an die scheuer exakt dasselbe gilt
übrigens fürs tempo limit aber das
verstößt gegen den gesunden
menschenverstand hast du gesagt
andererseits kann man die aktion ja auch
mal rein künstlerisch bewerten meint
dietmar wischmeyer deutschland verfehlt
sämtliche klimaziele und der zuständige
minister schlug nur noch mit den füßen
aus dem entern der autoindustrie
umso erstaunlicher dass er trotzdem zeit
findet uns als fotokünstler mit einem
provokanten bilderzyklus zu überraschen
dieses bild trägt den titel fahrer von
hinten und erzählt die anrührende
geschichte zweier junger menschen die
sich bei einem unfall auf dem radweg
kennengelernt haben beide sind erschöpft
und mussten sich hingegen während er
sich schon in stellung bringt zögert sie
noch und schein zu fragen ist so ein
fahrradhelm wirklich ein geeignetes
verhütungsmittel
das zweite motiv aus der sammlung steuer
zeigt einen jungen haften stricher im
postkeller depression auch attac
rätselhafterweise einen fahrradhelm
was ist geschehen hat der letzte freie
eben die luftpumpe geklaut
pizza boten den eine kundin als lebende
vorspeise fernab tag deutlich umschifft
der künstler hier den vorwurf des
sexismus in dem einen übellaunigen mann
als opfer darstellt auch das schlussbild
des steuer zyklus wirft fragen auf warum
hat keiner dieser angeblichen radfahrer
ein fahrrad arbeit und warum schubbern
sie aneinander roambi notgeile fig
frösche kein deutscher fahrradverkehr
doch nur so aufregend wäre realität ist
leider nicht ganz so attraktiv wie diese
erschreckenden aber das wirklich an
kirchen eine kampagne in zusammenarbeit
mit der prosieben show germany's next
topmodel für die unsere reichs domina
heidi klum 14-jährige bei wasser und
salat über die laufstege prügelt und
doch findet steuer nachahmer hier die
neue kampagne von ursula von der leyen
looks like shit und fliegt auch nicht
gut an
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort